kind of opening
opening word which consists of
the crux of the Islamic belief.
That is that the prophet taught
his companions for person
wishes to address a people or
wishes to or there's some
things, some occasion, the
prophet would often begin this
occasion with what is referred
as it is the address of the
occasional address meaning that
any occasion any ceremonious
thing, marriage, addressing the
people on on or giving a class
or and many of our scholars as
well begin their books. They
begin writing their books with
they begin their often times
with they begin their letters
to one another often times with
Hajj et cetera. This is is
referred to as and this some
have become Muslim just by
hearing from the prophet it
consist of a few phrases that
essentially in summary
include all of the main beliefs
of the Muslim. So goes as
follows. In all praise indeed
is due to Allah. We praise him.
We seek aid in him. And we seek
forgiveness. In him. And we
seek we seek refuge in Allah.
from the evil of ourselves and
from thee
evil of our deeds and the ill
effects of our deeds. Whomever
Allah guides, there is nothing
that can misguide him. And
whomever Allah misguides, then
there is nothing and noone that
can guide him. And I hereby
testify that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah. And I
further testify that Muhammad
is his servant and his
messenger. And then he would
recite 3 verses of the Quran
102nd verse of
you who have believed observe
the obedience and reverence of
Allah as he is due and do not
die except as Muslims. Then he
follows that with the first
verse of
people. Observe the obedience
and reverence of your lord who
has created you all from a
single soul and from that soul,
he has created its spouse. And
from those two souls, he has
dispersed throughout the earth.
Many people, countless people.
To the end of the verse. And
then the seven and 71st verse
of oh you who have believed,
observe the obedience and
reverence of Allah and speak
with a clear, defined speech.
If you do so, your lord will
better and rectify for you your
deeds. And he will forgive you
your sins. And whoever obey
Allah and his messenger then
this individual has truly
succeeded a great success. This
is essentially what the prophet
would begin many addresses,
speeches, marriages, etcetera
with. And as you can see, the
this opening address is very
profound in its meanings. It
gives us a clear, concise
instruction about our life here
on this Earth and our
relationship with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Sharba,
Sharbab Narhajaj, Radi Allahhu
Anu, one of the great scholars
of hadith. As a matter of fact,
is one of the few memorizers of
Hadith in the history of Islam
who was crowned Amir Al Muminin
Fal Hadith. The highest level
any person can achieve because
in the science of Hadith, each
narrator of Hadith has a level.
The scholars assess their
level. Their well eyes, their
mistakes, if they're very few,
if their mistakes are more
numerous, what kind of mistakes
they make, right? And so
there's many levels with
regards to an a narrator. The
highest level a person can ever
get is a very few people were
allotted this title such as Al
Imam Al Bukhari, Imam Muslim,
these great scholars, Sharba,
Rahima Allah is one of the few
in the history of Islam that
was referred to as Amir Al
hadith. It's almost unheard of
that ever made a mistake in
narrating hadith. He said, I
asked this this opening address
Is it should it be only a part
of the opening address in
marriage? Or in other things as
well, he said, Yani Abuz Hauk
responded and said, in all of
heirs. Meaning, anything in
which you're addressing other
people and this thing has some
kind of some kind of weight.
This address has some kind of
weight. You're addressing other
people and some kind of event
or some kind of ceremonious
occasion. Is what usually the
prophet would begin with. part
of that is in marriage. You
know, when a person does a
marriage contract, Oftentimes,
the companions, the they would
begin with after which they
would do, you know, hijab. So,
the point is, is that is
something that is very
important for us to learn and
memorize if we can. To memorize
and more importantly, to
memorize its meanings, very
important.
There is a lot of mistakes that
take place with regards to
opening religious addresses.
the
[Silence]
What has been narrated of the
words of the prophet and the
companions. It doesn't mean
that a person has to do if they
wish to give a doesn't mean
have to start with if they wish
to write a book or a letter
what have you? No. rather it
should be something that is
along the lines of meaning
praise of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala beginning with the
praise of Allah beginning with
the name of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. beginning with a
reminder to oneself and his
fellow Muslims despite
etcetera. This is what a person
should do when it comes to
religious affairs, religious
ceremonies. Sometimes we see
that people for instance, if
they wish to give a or
something, they begin with for
instance. This is something
that hasn't been narrated of
the actions of the prophet or
the companions. It's important
that we maintain the sunnah of
the prophet in these issues.
Also, when it comes to speaking
at events that are not
religious or topics that are
not religious topics, you know,
a person can essentially say
whatever is appropriate but
when it comes to religious
issues, a a class, a any
address that is a religious
dress, etcetera. It's important
that we stick to the of the
prophet there's you know books
written and stuff about public
speaking and how to speak in
public and and get people's
attention, and have charisma
and have these kinds of things
and they give you little tips
and pointers. You know, you
should start with a joke or
open with something
lighthearted or whatever it is.
This maybe appropriate in a
setting other than this kind of
setting. marriage or or
class or lecture or an address
or something that. It's
important that we maintain the
prophet in such matters.
The prophet also tells us that
if a person marries or if a
person
purchases a ride a a camel
or an our time a car or
something that that a
person should start with making
dua to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala that Allah grant him
blessing in this marriage or in
this purchase and that the
person should begin their
initial interaction with the
name of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And he taught us as
well for this which translates
to oh Allah I ask you of these
things good and the good of
what it was created and
designed with and constructed
and I seek refuge in you from
its evil and the evil of that
which it was created upon.
Another thing is the prophet
dua for someone who has newly
married. That would be as
follows A person just got
married, you would say to him
may Allah give you blessing. He
can shower you with blessing.
And may Allah unite you and
your spouse in all good.
Another thing he taught us is
our reaction to tragedy. If a
person sees someone who has
been afflicted with a tragedy
or a crisis or a hardship. He
taught us a dua. That dua is
Alhamdulillah. Allah the
he tells us that if a person
sees another going through a
crisis or afflicted with a
tragedy or hardship If upon
seeing this affliction, a
person makes the following dua
which translates to all praise
is due to Allah, the one who
has spared me from that which
he has afflicted you with. And
he has granted me merit over
much of that which he has
created, a great merit indeed.
That if a person makes this dua
upon seeing someone in a time
of affliction or crisis. That's
this particular crisis or this
particular
affliction, he will be spared
from it no matter what it is.
The prophet was also
in a gathering of the
companions and
superstition was mentioned
Person taking a bad omen from
something that they see. and so
this is referred to in the
Arabic language as
originally comes from the root
word which is a bird. And that
is that the pre-Islamic Arabs
they were very superstitious
people. And one of their
superstitions is that they
would always look for
foreboding omens. So for
instance if they saw a lizard
or if they saw a bird that is
sitting, they may
they may disturb this bird. You
know, throw a little stone at
it or something to get it
moving and then, they would
closely watch this bird's
reaction. So, if the bird went
right for instance, that would
be a good omen but if the bird
took flight left, then, this
would be a bad omen. And we
have lots of things that
in every culture does. it
can be a place or it could be a
time or it could be a date or a
day of the week, or a month of
the year, or it could be a
particular action or a
particular number. So, for
instance, in the west here, in
many places throughout the
world, the number thirteen is
considered to be very ominous.
, as a matter of fact, many
airplanes don't even have a
13th aisle. It just goes twelve
and then fourteen. Likewise,
the 13th floor is often omitted
it's usually, you know, 12
and fourteen. There is no 13th
floor or thirteenth room or
13th seat. This is considered
to be an ominous date or an
ominous number. Likewise,
Friday the thirteenth is
considered to be an ominous
date. likewise, you know,
black cats for instance, and
there's a lot of superstitions,
you know, lot of superstitions
having to do with mirrors. If a
person breaks a mirror or if a
person walks under a ladder or
if a person opens an umbrella
indoors or if a person, you
know, there's a lot of things
and these silly superstitions
have no bearing on reality.
They have no bearing on a on a
Muslim's life. The only thing
that should be taken from these
things are that those things
which are considered to be good
omens, right? because always
looking for hopeful omens is
something that encourages a
person to think good thoughts
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and expect the best from Allah
at all times. The prophet tells
us about these omens. He says,
that omens do not repel a
Muslim. And if you see
something that you consider to
be ominous, then you are to
make the following dua.
Oh Allah, none brings about
good. Except for you.
And
none repels bad. But you.
And there is no strength there
is no change, there is nothing
of of positive or any strength
or power or ability or change
that comes about except by you
and through you. So, no matter
what, a Muslim grows up and
there's going to be
superstitions that are in the
public consciousness. You know,
of us depending on where we
came from you know, if if we
feel that the number thirteen
is an ominous number because
you know, it's been drilled
into us over time or that a
black cat walking across your
path, crossing in front of you
is considered to be ominous or
any of these things. A person
may feel apprehensive in their
heart but what's important is
not that a person not feel
disapprension but that this
thing that is considered
ominous not repel the person
from what they're going to do.
If you're going to get on a
plane or if you're going to
stay in a hotel or if you're
going to do something and that
you know, ominous thing comes
up, it should not repel you.
Say, well, let me get a
different room or let me take a
different flight or something
that. That is haram.
However, if a person, you know,
has this feeling, they make
this dua and they continue in
whatever it is they are
endeavoring to do.
A Mean Allah.
Shaitan.